the origins of the bunny girl costume
date back to the iconic Playboy bunny a
costume developed by the aforementioned
Playboy enterprise for a woman to wear
at their clubs and has since become a
worldwide icon of sex appeal and
seduction eventually weaving its way to
Japan where it found a new surge of
popularity rising in prominence in
Japanese media especially in the form of
anime and manga and through this comes
one of the hottest show this season
rascal does not dream of bunny girl
senpai a show which has absolutely
nothing to do with bunny girls rendering
this entire opening paragraph [ __ ]
bunny girl senpai is one of my favorite
anime airing right now that is no small
feat in a season more stacked in the 13
level car tower being built so I just
wanted to talk about it for a bit
alright because there wasn't anything
more misleading than a title on a poster
that implied this is gonna be some kind
of generic light novel fanservice
rom-com Hey look we've got bunny girls
this time you're stupid enough to watch
this because it has bunny girls in it
which I was only to be hit but one of
the most touching addicting and
well-written character dramas I've seen
all year dealing with the social
pressures in psychology surrounding our
adolescence and growing up so today I
just wanted to show some love you know
just shed a bit of light for any of you
who may have overlooked this thanks to
the title and the poster and of course
answer the pressing question on
everyone's mind why is it called rascal
does not dream of bunny girl Sam pie I
don't [ __ ] rabbit grill senpai was
made by Studio clover works which is
actually an offshoot of a-1 pictures who
if you didn't know he's the powerhouse
studio that made super popular anime
like zetas yellow grease Xinhua in 2008
that's it that's all they've done
there's literally nothing else
noteworthy to talk about so I don't
think we're gonna find any more clues
here details the stoic adventures a
smartass pricks actor as he encounters
different girls afflicted by this
phenomenon known as puberty syndrome
what is this mysterious puberty syndrome
well in the plot synopsis it's described
as abnormal experiences rumoured on the
insect to be caused by sensitivity and
instability during adolescence yeah I
know what you mean like balls dropping
body
growing period starting dr. Google I
wonder if there's already a name for all
these symptoms that exist that this show
might be miss are you [ __ ] kidding me
the show doesn't adequately express in
its title or plot synopsis is what
pewdie syndrome actually is though even
if you watch the show it isn't that
simple to describe either the syndrome
is basically some kind of supernatural
phenomenon that is essentially a
manifestation of a problem someone is
going through for example you can have
cut suddenly appearing on a teenage girl
who's getting cyber bullied or a local
celebrity literally disappearing from
everyone's perception due to her
internal conflicts of wanting to be in
the public eye and so what the series is
about is following our main lead as he
helps various characters through their
personal problems and thus overcoming
the puberty syndrome that has affected
them now I know what you're thinking
okay Oh a guy going around solving
different supernatural phenomena
afflicting girls in an arc format
complete with witty dialogue what is
this the new season of monogatari
without the head tilts [ __ ] what does
that make the watch order now [ __ ]
Monica tree then ease him on a gut read
then you got this new season normy
monogatari well there is that
reminiscent feel to a lot of these other
well-known lights novel adaptations
namely the monogatari franchise or a
guru and maybe even a slight dash of
harry he I do feel the comparisons stop
past the surface level and Bonnie girl
is really able to carve out his own
identity soccer and hajiman may give off
similar vibes both being loners with a
similar life outlook but the reasoning
behind their character traits are
entirely different
socata is more about purposely ignoring
the social norms he reads the atmosphere
and chooses to go against it and is very
different from how humans pessimistic
narcissism as for the Monica tree girls
they were meant to be a play on the
cliched anime character archetypes
subverting our expectations of these
traits we are used to and building them
up to be characters with far greater
depth than we would usually see and
because of this the aberrations are
nothing like the adolescents syndrome
because the reasoning characters are
affected by the syndrome is totally
different you have characters which on
the surface are dealing with issues and
insecurity is a lot of us face or mayor
faced during adolescence and puberty
characters you may start off having a
distaste for eventually become likeable
when you find out what experiences in
their lives made them this way because
even if you can't personally relate to
them you at least come to understand
them well the adolescent syndrome does
is it ups the stakes it forces these
character
to confront their deepest fears and
flaws in a short period of time and what
this meant for me is that I got
incredibly invested incredibly fast
every character gets developed through
the course of their arc that is quick
but feels natural thanks to the
situation they've been put in by the end
of episode 3 you've already been on this
emotional journey and you think to
yourself wow that could have been the
series climax right there and then you
slowly realize that holy [ __ ] you're
only three [ __ ] episodes in every
character something different to say and
the adolescent syndrome also manifests
in some crazy but interesting ways
there's even an arc where the main
character has to live through a constant
time loop of being woken up by his
little sister which um you know didn't
trigger any PTSD for myself or anything
we're forgetting the real reason
adolescent syndrome is different from
other supernatural phenomenon an anime
you see because at least Bonnie Gail's
Empire actually explains its phenomenon
see there's bound to be people confuse
us towards adolescents injure match the
years but actually the show takes us
into account so it makes these
phenomenon easier to understand for the
average person by describing it using
theories of quantum mechanics let me
just say the last sentence again
[ __ ] explanations of quantum
mechanics aside another thing that
absolutely stands out is the chemistry
between the characters and the dialogue
aside from the format of the show
solving supernatural phenomenon in each
arc I feel this is where most people got
the monogatari vibes from and I use that
as a compliment the writing is
incredibly witty and makes simple
exchanges between characters incredibly
engaging especially between our main duo
instead of just having one sarcastic get
everyone's a smartass and everyone's
trying to constantly get the
conversation or high ground so the
dialogue feels less like an exchange of
words and more like a boxing match of
wits and this makes the conversation
about the most mundane of topics so
addicting to watch I never once got
bored just watching people [ __ ] with
each other there I'm not sure how
healthy it is to admire this dialogue I
mean I couldn't help but get charmed by
sucked his deadpan straightforwardness
of just saying whatever is on his mind
but you get to a point where you're
watching him saying the most grossly
inappropriate [ __ ] with your normal
social situations you should never say
out loud but in your mind you're like
huh so my
it they'll cook a cold I got off
same though I am missing the number one
reason why anyone would want to watch
this show and of course that is the
funny my friend baby
it is rare you get to see a show of so
many aids here wife used to pick from I
mean help a guy out here buddy girls
Empire there are only so many smiles I
can protect so many times my heart can
skip a beat so many dojinshi that I can
reno see what the classes like wars this
you get to choose between a variety of
so many amazing girls and qaeda you've
got Koga you've got Futaba and two
lovely flavors you've got someone who's
done nothing but watch error mumbles on
say her entire life I've done you've got
the latest addition yet through all this
there's one that stands head and
shoulders above the rest and that is of
course our main girl baby Gaara herself
my Sakurajima who just has a perfect mix
of dry wits a strong but tender heart a
blush worth dying for and provide you
with unexpected moments of cuteness with
her just don't like sprinkle cinnamon
there if weif wisdom was an art she'd be
the Sistine [ __ ] Chapel of wifey's
but you know instead of leaving you in
boar she just make you melt into a ball
pink fluff blossom we're Lucia he's
dying
that is basically bunny girl senpai the
anime that has nothing to do with bunny
girls aside from like two scenes all I
know I have to say that bunny cows
Empire has been absolutely incredible so
far when I just started watching it it
was hard for me to pinpoint exactly why
I connected with the show so quickly and
while I could dive deeper into the
overall meaning of adolescence syndrome
as a concept at its core I don't think
it was that complicated for me you take
out the strange supernatural phenomenon
you take out the BS quantum mechanics or
the influences it borrows from and what
you're left with is very human
characters coming to terms with their
problems problems many of us could have
faced during our time in high schools as
teenagers there doesn't always need
a supernatural force to manifest our
deepest flaws and insecurities that are
ever so present in this digitally
connected era cyberbullying the fear of
being judged by our social norms our
online perception versus our actual
perceptions and just coming to accept
parts of us that we hate many may write
off the difficulties we face in high
school as dumb teenage angst but that
isn't always the case some of these
issues follow us into adulthood some of
us still wear those same insecurities we
gained during that time every day of our
lives
they didn't just magically disappear
when we got older and it's our
experiences when growing up that
dictates how we approach these problems
as adults
bunny-girl senpai manages to capture
this sentiment in a wholly unique way it
shows us what would have happened if
someone was there to help us tackle
these trials head-on when we were
younger written with the kind of dry
chemistry you rarely get to see whether
you watch it for the various problems
the addicting dialogue the lovable cast
or my in the yard Bonnie girl outfit
you'd be doing yourself a disservice by
missing the show because at the end of
the day rascal may not dream of bunny
girl senpai for dear lord I [ __ ] do
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month to Joseph
Warren supreme sayin sundown fun sisters
one zero zero eight six Ella for and
everyone else in my picture I hope
you've spoiled me for this month and
making this video possible
I know it's been a while since my last
upload but love that's been preparation
for this month I've got a lot of videos
planned this month plus the end-of-year
review as well so it's gonna be a pretty
[ __ ] busy month for me last year I
only had one day off the entire month
and that was Christmas Day
so um I'm hoping it's not gonna be a
repeat of that this year anyway though
that's it for me hope you haven't missed
me too much I've been give up and until
then I will see you all next time
shaaka